isabelle morini-bosc la saison est
bientôt finie je vous le dis noise des
émissions il me reste dix émissions avec
vous les cherry et hier benjamin
castaldi à une note de 6,8 sur douce et
bien isabelle morini-bosc vous êtes
souvent la meilleure élève de l'année
est-ce que vous allez encore la
meilleure élève de l'année on va le voir
tout de suite déjà petit résumé de la
saison
isabelle morini-bosc regarde et c'est
parti pour le conseil de classe de
manille isabelle isabelle morini bosc
c'est avant tout des interventions
passionnante vient de deux ans leurs
parents s'inquiètent après les u 19 de
moyenne générale par tous les chats
penser oui ça aide ça des dents des
morsures à une force herculéenne un jeu
dont je me fiche totalement
une journaliste de talons spécialisé
dans les médias ça ne contenant pas papa
thierry sa baisse à me répondre comme ça
mais surtout dans la danse
[Applaudissements]
isabelle c'est aussi la seule
chroniqueuse capable de partir en fou
rire tout seul sans aucune raison c'est
à dire le cheikh brahim et de quoi le
cher et mieux la cus et quand elle ne
rigole pas mamie à galles isabelle
pardon c'est aussi se faire respecter
quitte à s'en prendre physiquement à ses
voisins tard agression sur un mannequin
sa cible préférée gilles verdez jamais
regretté qu'elle sait jamais pourquoi tu
laissant alors de gilles verdez à gilles
de la tourette
il n'y a qu'un pas on était vraiment la
couille si j'ose dire bref cette année
encore isabelle nous a offert une saison
riche en émotions et pour ça on peut lui
dire merci mamie
m
c'est le cas d'isabelle mans au liban et
valérie bénaïm votre appréciation et
votre note bon alors maïza évidemment tu
fais une très bonne élève tu n'as plus
rien à prouver ici ça fait quoi à cinq
ans six ans déjà 50 55 ans que 50 en
cinq ans on est ensemble que tu poses
tes fesses sur les tabourets de tpm paix
et franchement ça avec plaisir j'adore
le duo le duo muppet show que tu formes
avec gilles parce que c'est sain c'est
un duo des pet shop vous gueulez dessus
régulièrement où vous tapez la fois tu
le tap et lui t'embrasse je sais pas
pourquoi d'ailleurs les tu connais le
milieu tu connais le métier donc là
dessus aucun souci deux bémols en
revanche cette petite tendance à être
parfois à côté du sujet c'est à dire que
nous on est passé à autre chose de toi
tu est carrément ou sur un autre sujet
ou sur le sujet précédent
et puis la fameuse cécile tendance à
radoter avec le le fameux vos muette
plusieurs sur un bon coup que seul sur
un mauvais ou encore tu pues ce que tu
disais voilà
mais malgré ces deux petites choses tu
est évidemment le pile un pilier de
touche pas à mon poste et donc pour ça
je te mets l'excellent bravo
[Applaudissements]
volonté isabelle nanty isabelle jeu je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui est
indispensable dans cette équipe c'est
vraiment un des piliers si ce n'est le
pilier de la bande
je la trouve tout menace dans ses avis
punaise parce que même des fois elle
réussit à placer des anecdotes qui n'ont
rien à voir et que je raconte mais elle
y va elle lâche pas le morceau et en
plus elle a énormément d'autodérision
sur elle le petit défaut si je te trouve
trop gentille de temps en temps parce
que tu encaisses toutes les vannes
mais toi quand tu en fais sur les autres
tu sens le vide se justifier comme la
semaine dernière avec christine j'étais
franchement c'est s'était jetée pas la
peine parce qu'on si tout le monde
savait que c'était une vanne donc pour
ça je dis est ce que c'est vraiment un
défaut je te mets un excellent 9
mathieu mammy mammy plein qualité ap les
principales qualités je tu vois bien
tentant bien qu'on pense que di turi tu
réagis tu te move dans l'espace ça ça
c'est les qualités alors les défauts les
défauts d'apporter un petit peu nos
espoirs c'est un peu souci tu dis par
exemple c'est toujours un peu tu dis tu
crées tepa m6 alors que t'as jamais
critiqué l'émission de m6 tu dis que tu
couches tous les mets toutes les
semaines avec ton mari alors comment des
bus et mensuels ben non mais c'est vrai
j'étais un petit peu les choses
tu dis que tu veux que l'argent ça
t'intéresse pas avorter cannes tous les
jours au maquillage même contient à
prime bon bref voilà un petit peu de
mauvaise foi et après ton principal
défaut mamie c'est que sur les
interventions tu pars sur un truc tu des
rides
on sait pas où tu vas c'est dur 3
plombes ça me fait penser un petit peu à
quoi je vais chez ma grand mère c'est à
dire sur le chemin voiture je suis hyper
content d'y aller mais une fois que je
suis là bas j'avoue que je regarde un
petit peu ma montre j'ai qu'une envie
c'est de me casser la foule était là que
je ressens quand tu parles mais voilà
mais à côté de ça j'ai beaucoup
d'affection pour toi et je suis content
d'être à côté de toi voilà note à ma
note 6 même si c'est pas marisa
[Applaudissements]
moi j'adore isabelle c'est pas un secret
et est ce que j'aime le plus chez toi
c'est ton sens de l'autodérision soit
que vous êtes à personne et tu les
personnes qui acceptent plus de choses
sur ce bateau les vannes de salopards de
l'ormeau le monde sur l'année ma part à
là ça c'est la vie la principale qualité
après c'est vrai que les scoop c'est
souvent de chez toi que ça vient donc
pour ça j'adore après j'ai remarqué un
très grave cette année et la joue
vraiment à faire un appel au médecin qui
nous regarde tu n'entends plus rien et
là il faut il faut absolument se faire
appareiller parce que les déchets
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
crois autant d'informations je crois
c'est pas vrai mamie tu crois entendu
dans une arène et tu parles sur autre
chose et ça effectivement cessé pour moi
ça me perturbe pas ce que moi j'ai du
mal à articuler about what a du mal à
entendre
non mais les deux fait jamais dit non
deux comme comme comme tu entends un mot
sur 2g / de génissac voilà quand même
quand même c'est pas ouf mais ces
conseils de classe d'isabelle jean
michel maire alors isabelle tu sais que
tu es notre mascotte donc nos je t'en
supplie ne couvre pas mal
les quelque chose que je dire sur toi
mais je les dis parce que tu sais que je
t'adore voilà un très gros point fort et
tous et c'est que tu arrives à rester
éveillé à peu près toutes les émissions
jusqu'à la fin de son éloquence a déjà
un bel exploit tout le monde ne le fait
pas mais malheureusement tu as des
points faibles et les points faibles
sont notre surtout due à de
l'indiscipliné et ça c'est impardonnable
je penserai d'accord avec toi tu
marmonne énormément malgré le fait que
le chef se le dise à chaque fois d'arrêt
de marmonner isabelle lavigne ou pas oui
mais vous je vous ai dit aussi qu'ils
ont il connaît donc je continue donc je
garais le gars c'est comme le foot il
est crypté franc suivant la parole alors
que tu n'as pas l'autorisation en
gueulant pensant qu'à lui suffit de
parler fort pour la parole art que nous
on aime on lève le doigt sache mans
cyril on est d'accord
voilà peu tendance à un peu tout ramener
à toi dans ce sens je supporte réty j'ai
travaillé dans un zoo j'ai fait par
pékin express jetons et rachid arhab
personnellement dernière dernière chose
d'un peu de tendance à dire que tout et
son contraire à chaque fois en ponctuant
tes phrases par en revanche et dira l'un
vertes de là on était parti donc ça je
poussais ça manque un peu de punch mais
je t'adore donc avec tout mon amour je
te mets trois que je regrette un peu que
j'aurais mis plus si j'avais été pas de
bonne humeur
sévère on le connaît il est sévère c'est
vrai on attend bien sûr avec impatience
géraldine m'a dit alors mes chers is as
tu connais toi on dirait qu'elle écrit
de la plus ici dans le london le soleil
n'est pas au rendez vous j'ai connu
certaines personnes qui quitteraient
mots qui nous qui dit méritait le détour
ariza qui donne tout tu connais tous
tuerie de tous - contrairement à jean ni
ce que j'aime c'est que justement tu es
à contre-courant moi j'aime tes en
revanche gmt néanmoins ça donne de la
nuance alors quand on est une époque
justement sans nuance et donc ça c'est
absolument formidable moi je trouve
absolument merveilleuse je pense que tu
es un pilier absolu de la bo de la bande
en revanche je t'enlève de points parce
que tu nous dis toujours que tu freeze
et je t'ai jamais vu frisé valoir en
scotcher narratif in tune très longtemps
[Applaudissements]
perreault nouvelle s'inquiète pas et ça
ça me fait plaisir
non mais c'est avoir ému comme si nos
besoins comme la fario femme qui est
d'élever d'ovh hélas oui alors il a jeté
décerne le prix de la reine de la barca
chez toi c'est ce que j'adore danser
avec toi je m'éclate avec toi tu es une
de celle qui m'a le mieux accueilli ici
et pour ça je te serai toujours
reconnaissante
tu es une de celles qui travaillent le
plus qu'à le plus d'infos le plus de
scoops et et voilà je te porte vraiment
dans mon coeur et pour ça je te mets un
joli mythe
elle va pas tarder à tmx et oui non je
sais pas si j'aurais dû finir par l'idée
mais tu t'en fous tu son habillage ils
n'ont jamais non ah ouais merde alors
isabelle à lyon qu'il ya un parc estimé
isabelle vous déclinez physique n'est
pas physiquement vous est à l'apogée de
votre beauté et c'est la chroniqueuse
qui est en plein naufrage
autre point fort vous n'en avez plus qu
un c'est alain met alors à toutes les
anecdotes toutes les histoires moi je
vais parler alain il est tabou la baisse
amoureux j'étais là il n'en peut plus
toutes les anecdotes plus la panna cotta
le week-end arrêté faut lâcher un peu
vos points faibles
la liste est très longue comme sa série
de télé au début oui alors mes points
faibles comme syrie est impatient je
vais raccourcir la liste mais
franchement j'en prends trois les trois
principaux vous radotez vous délirez est
beaucoup plus grave
vous êtes isabelle morini bosc à la
solde de m6 et ça vous ne pouvez pas le
nier mais comme vous êtes mon unis
ouazine la seule qui me supporter pour
cette unicité
je vous mets la magnifique note 2 1
[Rires]
allez fais si l'on finit par vous alors
moi j'ai à chaque fois la beauce ont été
conviés dans cette émission de la nuit
je voulais en fait c'est vrai chacun sa
personnalité je trouve franchement cyril
oui je trouve le conseil de classe
dégueulasse je peux vous dire c'est pas
gentil avec les autres mais c'est bien
gentil tout ça mais je dis ça sinon
franchement et j'habite à moi tous ces
liens dernière c'est plutôt gentil mais
moi j'ai du mal alors j'apprendrai je
vais être papa ça va être beau tout va
vous de confiance non mais en revanche
comme dirait isa j'ai l'habitude de dire
que quand on est au csa on a pris des
baffes je crois qu'on a pris tellement
de battre c'est ça que lorsque je
raconte les gens pleurent de ce que moi
j'ai vécu personnellement au csa donc je
pense que j'ai encore le client plutôt
épais isabelle je t'aime je les points
positifs autodérision très grande
autodérision
je suis incapable d'avoir une auto
dérision comme toi deuxièmement grande
répartie comme matthieu delormeau qui
n'est pas la davie reading room réparti
les participants
troisièmement tu cherches des infos et
je me rappelle un jour j'étais venu en
1/4 ou non mais et tu avais pris mon
portable parce que voilà tu es tu
cherches tu es info tu es une
journaliste j'apprécie s'il faut
vraiment chercher un point faible je
dirais que tu râles un petit peu mais
c'est vraiment parce qu'il faut chercher
je t'aime je t'apprécie beaucoup et ma
femme merveilleuse accueillis
avec une telle excitation
on a du souci à madame est la raison
géraldine a la mérite sur 20 ans et
habite sur 20 ans avec un trait sur dix
a alors un site web
[Applaudissements]
10,8 sur 10 un bravo usa d'amour et moi
que vénus c'est vrai tu étais messieurs
vivien mais je sais que c'est des
émotions ça je peux même vous de la bd
trop de trucs gentils